.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Kann man im Leben
immer wieder neu anfangen?
Für ihr gemeinsames Glück
haben die beiden Frauen
Mann, Kind und Betrieb verlassen.
In mir drin sah ich unseren Weg
eigentlich schon immer.
Es ist ...
- Von Anfang an?
Ja. Nach dem ersten Kuss.
Und was, wenn einen das Schicksal
zu einem brutalen Neuanfang zwingt?
Emil Kindschi wurde als Junge
zu Hause auf dem Bauernhof
von einem Traktor überfahren.
Im April 2018
dachten wir auch nicht,
dass wir im Mai dieses Schicksal
aufgebürdet kriegen würden.
Man muss jeden Tag nehmen,
wie er kommt.
Was ist mit jenen,
die nicht nur für sich,
sondern für die ganze Gesellschaft
einen Neuanfang wollen?
Wie kann das funktionieren?
Die Klimabewegung
steht an einem Wendepunkt.
Für eine soziale Bewegung gibt es
keine Alternative zur Strasse.
In der Pandemie hat eine neue
Bewegung die Strassen besetzt.
Gesellschaftlich zielt die
in eine ganz andere Richtung.
Muss man sich bewaffnen?
- Äh ...
Bist du bewaffnet?
- Ja, ganz klar.
Was braucht es,
damit ein Neuanfang gelingt?
Dieser Frage gehe ich jetzt nach.
Meine Reise
fängt im Berner Oberland an.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich bin unterwegs
ins Reka-Feriendorf an der Lenk.
Anstatt Feriengästen
wohnen dort im Moment
ukrainische Flüchtlinge,
die hier in der Schweiz
irgendwie neu anfangen sollen.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass ein Filmteam
in der vorübergehenden Unterkunft
für Geflüchtete aus der Ukraine
Aufnahmen machen darf.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
"Reka-Feriendorf".
Ich treffe mich mit Miroszlava Burok.
Das ist die Frau,
die hier die Fäden zusammenhält.
Ja, Mira.
Lebt oder arbeitet sie hier?
Das ist ihr Büro.
Hello.
- Hello. I'm Mona.
Du bist ...
- Mira. Hoi. Freut mich.
Mira, sollen wir uns duzen?
Ich bin Mona. Freut mich.- Ja.
Das ist unser Arbeitsplatz.
Ist das dein Büro?
- Das ist unser Büro.
Das ist mein Kollege.
- Mona.- Michael. Freut mich.
Michael.
Was machst du alles hier?
Was sind deine Aufgaben?
Ich bin Sachbearbeiterin,
Betreuerin und Dolmetscherin.
Zusammen mit Mira arbeiten
sehr unterschiedliche Menschen
in diesem
kurzfristig entstandenen Team:
Lehrerinnen, Reka-Angestellte
oder Leute wie Michael Stucki
von der Organisation
Asyl Bern Oberland,
die auch Mira anstellt.
Aktuell ist Mira dabei, Wohnungen
für die Geflüchteten zu suchen.
Die Zusammenarbeit im Team
sei sehr gut, sagt Mira.
Im Reka-Dorf sind v.a.
Frauen und Kinder untergebracht.
Für alle
ist es eine vorübergehende Station.
Eine erstes Ankommen.
Ein Anfang in der Schweiz.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Polinka, bist du schön brav?
Ich bin Mona.
Wir treffen Kateryna Maryniuk.
Welches ist deine Tochter?
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Kateryna
ist mit ihrer Tochter Viktoria
aus dem Südosten der Ukraine
geflüchtet.
Ihre Stadt ist momentan
von russischen Truppen besetzt.
Hat sie einen Mann oder Familie dort?
* Sie dolmetscht. *
Da.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Ihr Mann
ist jetzt auch in der Armee.
Und die Familie ist auch noch dort.
- Ja. Ja.
Wie halten sie Kontakt,
wenn sie hier sind?
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
Im Moment
können sie nicht kommunizieren,
weil es keine Verbindung gibt.
- Uff.
Du weisst nicht, wo dein Mann ist
oder wie es deinen Verwandten geht?
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
Nein.
- Leider nicht.- Ja.
Das ist
wahnsinnig schwer vorstellbar.
Wie man das aushält.
Man sitzt hier
und kann nichts machen.
Man liest die Schlagzeilen,
sieht die Bilder -
was macht das mit den Menschen?
Wie hast du das erlebt?
Ich lese jeden Morgen
die Nachrichten.
Ich denke immer, dass ich
eines Morgens aufstehen werde
und lese,
dass der Krieg vorbei ist.
Das wünschst du dir.
- Das wünsche ich mir wahnsinnig.
Was läuft,
ist für mich wahnsinnig ungerecht.
Man ist einfach
irgendwann aufgewacht ...
... und hat gelesen,
dass Kyiv angegriffen wird.
Das war wie ein Albtraum.
Also ...
Dass sich die Geflüchteten
hier im Reka-Dorf
austauschen
und ihre Erfahrungen teilen können,
sei ein Glück für alle, sagt Mira.
Speziell für die Kinder.
* Die Kinder singen. *
Mira zeigt mir die Schule,
die kurzfristig aufgebaut wurde.
Ein pensioniertes Lehrerehepaar
aus der Lenk macht die Leitung.
Dazu kommen Lehrpersonen
und Hilfspersonal.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Ist sie Lehrerin?
- Sie ist Hilfslehrerin.
Okay.
Die 19-jährige Vlada Svirsh
lebt seit ihrer Flucht im Reka-Dorf.
Dürfen wir schnell stören?
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Hallo.
Zusammen mit ihrer Mutter verliess
sie ihre Heimat vor fünf Monaten.
Danke schön.
Es war sehr schwierig.
Am schwierigsten war es,
den Mut zu finden, um wegzugehen.
Und du selber?
Möchtest du in der Schweiz bleiben
und hier neu anfangen?
Oder möchtest du
zurück in die Ukraine?
Im Moment hoffe ich,
dass ich hier ein paar Jahre
bleiben und weiterstudieren kann.
Ich bin sehr froh,
dass ich einen Platz
an der Universität gefunden habe.
Du hast schon einen Platz
an einer Universität gefunden?
* Mira dolmetscht. *
Ah, super. Wo?
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
BFH ...
Fachr... Fachsch...
- Fachhochschule?
Fachhochschule in Biel.
- Wow, okay. Super.
Was studierst du dort?
* Mira dolmetscht. *
Computer Science.
- Computer Science. Informatik.
Okay. Wow.
Ich gratuliere. So schnell.
Vlada hofft, dass auch ihr Freund
in die Schweiz kommen kann.
Einen Studienplatz an der
Fachhochschule in Biel hat er schon.
Jetzt braucht er noch eine spezielle
Bewilligung des ukrainischen Staats,
zum Studieren ausreisen zu dürfen
und nicht ins Militär zu müssen.
Aber so klar
wie Vladas Zukunft aussieht ...
Sie weiss, dass sie hierbleiben
und studieren möchte.
Sie möchte ihren Freund hierherholen.
Aber so geht es
den wenigsten Menschen hier.
Die meisten sind momentan
noch total hin- und hergerissen
zwischen der Schweiz
und ihrer alten Heimat, der Ukraine,
wo gerade Krieg herrscht.
Das sieht man u.a.,
wenn man die Leute kennenlernt,
die mit Vlada in einer Wohnung leben.
Das sehen wir jetzt.
Vlada wohnt in einer Art WG
mit anderen ukrainischen Frauen.
Sie alle lernten sich
hier in der Schweiz kennen
und teilen sich
eine Dreizimmerwohnung.
Mit dabei ist auch Vladas Mutter.
Im Gegensatz zu Vlada ist die Zukunft
für sie noch völlig unklar.
Leider sehe ich kein Ende.
Ich habe Angst,
dass sich das noch lange hinzieht.
Und ich mache mir grosse Sorgen
um meine Familie und Freunde,
die in der Ukraine geblieben sind.
Komplett zwischen der Ukraine
und der Schweiz hin- und hergerissen
ist Natalia Kaminska.
Zusammen
mit ihrer 14-jährigen Tochter Alina
flüchtete sie
aus der umkämpften Stadt Charkiw.
Natalias Sohn wollte nicht mitkommen.
Darum will sie jetzt noch einmal in
die Ukraine zurück, um ihn zu holen.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
(Mira) Sie hat grosse Angst.
Natalia hat grosse Angst,
hat sie gesagt.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Sie hat keine Ahnung,
was dort auf sie wartet.
Unser Besuch geschieht am Vorabend
ihrer Rückreise in die Ukraine.
Wie es mittlerweile in ihrer
Heimatstadt Charkiw aussieht
und wie das Leben dort ist,
weiss sie nur von Bildern
von Verwandten,
Freunden und den sozialen Medien.
* Düstere Klänge *
Das Einzige, was Natalia Kaminska
in der Schweiz von ihrem Sohn hat,
ist ein Fotobuch
von ihm mit seiner Abschlussklasse.
Das ist Vitali.
Hier ist er 16 Jahre alt.
- Auf dem Bild ist er 16.
Im Herbst wird Vitali 18-jährig.
Ab dann ist er militärpflichtig
und darf nicht mehr
aus der Ukraine ausreisen.
Mein Sohn möchte ins Militär gehen.
Vielleicht weil sein bester Freund
auch gegangen ist.- Da.
Ich will noch einmal mit ihm reden,
bevor er 18 ist.
Vielleicht sagt er:
"Ja, Mama, ich komme zu dir."
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
(Mira dolmetscht) Ich hoffe sehr,
dass alles bald vorbei ist
und wir nach Hause zurückkönnen.
Ich möchte
wirklich nach Hause zurück.
* Düstere Klänge *
Ich hoffe sehr,
dass es Natalia gelingt,
ihren Sohn hierherzuholen.
Ich komme jedenfalls noch mal zurück,
um zu sehen, wie es ihr geht.
Ein Neuanfang ist nicht immer etwas,
das man aktiv sucht.
Manchmal ändert sich das Leben
von einem Tag auf den anderen
und man muss schauen,
wie man mit dem neuen zurechtkommt.
So erging es auch Familie Kindschi
und ihrem Sohn Emil.
Oh, so viele Leute.
- Das ist ja eine Begrüssung.
Komm.
- Hm? Hoi, hoi.
Bist du weit gefahren?
Emil Kindschi, vier Jahre alt
und stark pflegebedürftig.
Als Kleinkind wurde der Bub
von einem Traktor überfahren.
Ein schreckliches Unglück,
das von einem Tag auf den anderen
über die junge Familie
hereingebrochen ist.
Emil wächst auf einem Bauernhof auf.
Ein fröhlicher und aufgeweckter Bub
sei er gewesen, sagen die Eltern.
Mutter Ladina
hat den Bergbauernbetrieb
von den Eltern übernommen
und gemeinsam mit ihrem Mann Sven
bewirtschaftet.
Es war Frühling 2018,
als der Unfall geschah.
Auf diesem Hof im bündnerischen Pany.
Das Hauptereignis am Tag des Unfalls
passierte eigentlich hier.
Also,
der Unfall passierte da drüben.
Emils Grossvater
arbeitet mit dem Traktor.
Der Bub ist für einen kurzen Moment
unbeaufsichtigt.
Dann passiert es:
Der Grossvater überfährt
sein eineinhalbjähriges Grosskind
mit der schweren Maschine.
Seit dem Unfall
ist er ein gebrochener Mann.
Lebt mit der Schuld, ein junges Leben
kaputtgemacht zu haben.
Emil lag da,
und man sah eigentlich nichts.
Mein erster Gedanke war:
"Steh auf und geh weiter."
Man sah dann schon ...
Ich schaute dann genauer hin.
Ich wusste nicht, was passiert war.
Neni war oben ...
... und schrie.
Ich sah nur, dass Emil
Flecken auf der Stirn hatte.
Irgendwelche Spuren.
Und er blutete
aus der Nase und aus dem Ohr.
In dem Moment wusste ich,
dass es megaschlimm ist,
was da passiert ist.
Nicht nur einen Knall auf den Kopf
oder so.
Ich sagte zu Emil:
"Wir schaffen das -
egal, was jetzt passiert."
Sanität,
Rega und Polizei werden alarmiert.
Der Bub kommt auf die Notfallstation
des Kantonsspitals Chur.
Der Rega-Notarzt
kam dann raus und sagte,
er wisse nicht, ob Emil überlebe.
Er wünschte mir alles Gute und ging.
Dann sitzt man da und denkt:
"10 m weiter drüben kämpft mein Kind
jetzt gerade um sein Leben
und ich kann nichts machen."
Man kann wirklich nichts machen.
Dann kam Sven,
und ich hatte nur Angst.
Einen Monat
schwebt Emil zwischen Leben und Tod.
Mutter Ladina sagt, es sei gewesen,
als läge ihr Kind
in einem dunklen, tiefen Keller.
Emil überlebt.
Mit schweren Folgeschäden
des Unfalls.
Er ist körperlich
und geistig behindert.
Mit dem Unfall
wird er zu 100 % pflegebedürftig.
Die Beziehung zwischen den Eltern
Sven und Ladina geht in die Brüche.
Den Hof muss Ladina verpachten.
Wenn der Unfall nicht passiert wäre,
wären wir heute
noch eine intakte Familie.
Das muss ich klar sagen.
Wir hätten den Hof noch
und würden funktionieren.
Hätten Freude an Emil ...
Also an einem gesunden Kind.
Ja.
Absturz.
* Sie macht ein Fluggeräusch. *
Unzählige Operationen
muss Emil über sich ergehen lassen.
Eben ist er zurück
von einer Hüftoperation.
Noch einer. Pass auf.
* Sie macht ein Geräusch. *
Gehen lernen ist das grosse Ziel.
Ja. Komm.
Die Ärzte sagten, das werde
vielleicht nicht mehr so gut.
Man wisse nicht genau,
wo der Weg hinführe.
Heute muss ich sagen:
Er ist einfach cool.
Er macht seinen Weg.
Das ist sicher
auch seinem Umfeld zu verdanken.
Emils Papa, mir -
allen ist es zu verdanken,
dass Emil heute so sein kann,
wie er ist.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Knapp zwei Jahre sind vergangen
seit diesen Bildern von Emil.
Ich bin jetzt auf dem Weg,
um ihn und seine Familie zu besuchen.
Um zu sehen, wie es ihnen geht.
Darf ich einfach frech reinkommen?
- Ja, ja.- Bitte.
Platz.
Sven und Ladina Kindschi
sind zwar getrennt,
leben aber im gleichen Haus
und betreuen Emil zusammen.
Den kenne ich noch nicht. Mona.
- Keine Angst. Hoi. Sven.
Hoi.
- Mona. Hallo. Hoi, Emil.
Wie geht es dir? Hm?
Hey.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
Schau mal: Was ist das?
Eine Kamera. Hm?
Wenn ich Emil so sehe,
scheint megaviel passiert zu sein.
Was geht mittlerweile, das im Film
vielleicht noch nicht ging?
Emil geht jetzt seit fast einem Jahr
ins Schulheim Chur.
Dort hat er seine ganzen Therapien,
die ihm guttun, seine Freunde ...
Das ist super für ihn.
Er braucht andere Kinder.
Er braucht Action.
- Ja.
Am Ende des Films hatte er ja gerade
die Hüftoperation hinter sich.
Mittlerweile konnten die Platten
wieder rausgenommen werden.
Jetzt ist er bereit, um zu gehen.
Das Thema Gehen
ist nach wie vor ein grosses.
Wir dürfen auch daran arbeiten.
Langsam wird das jetzt Realität.
Wirklich?
- Man hofft ja immer darauf.
Die Hoffnung stirbt ja nie,
aber jetzt ist es greifbarer
als vor zwei Jahren.
Er hat gerade
unseren Tonmann entdeckt.
* Lachen *
Hm?
Möchtest du mal hören?
Jetzt müsst ihr was sagen.
Hallo, Emil. Hörst du die Mama?
Und Ätti?
Hm, hörst du mich?
- Der muss auch was sagen.
Wow.
- Hm? Das ist super, oder?
Wenn du daran drehst,
wird deine Mami lauter.
Wenn ich schimpfe, kannst du leiser
drehen und sonst lauter.
Machst du manchmal auch Mist?
- Ja, ja.
Er wirft Dinge auf den Boden.
* Emil kreischt. *
Hm? Er ist ein Schlitzohr.
Jetzt hat er eine Phase,
in der wohl gerade ...
Er fordert viel.
Das passiert uns ja allen.
Mich nimmt wunder,
wie sehr das Unglück -
die Wende im Leben der Familie -
im Alltag noch präsent ist.
Es kommt einem
jeweils schon wieder in den Sinn.
Aber nur kurz.
Es sind seither doch
schon fast vier Jahre vergangen.
Man vergisst es.
Das ist auch gut, ja.
Wenn er das so cool aufnehmen kann
und es für ihn okay ist,
ist es auch für mich okay.
Ja, genau.- Ja.
So.
(Roboterstimme) Ich möchte ...
- Mhm.
Warte.
Die Eltern zeigen mir,
wie Emil mit elektronischen
Hilfsmitteln kommunizieren lernt.
Trinken? Das?
Ja, hm?
- Du kommst gerade nicht draus.
Was haben wir noch zur Auswahl?
(Roboterstimme) Mineralwasser.
- Ach so. Mineralwasser. Sehr gut.
Vier Tage pro Woche
geht er in den Kindergarten.
Dort üben sie intensiv damit.
(Roboterstimme) Ich möchte Apfelsaft
trinken, nicht Mineralwasser.
Ja, jetzt ...
Jetzt wiederholt es den ganzen Satz.
Möchtest du das hier?
Emils Kindergarten
ist im Schulheim Chur.
Hallo zusammen. Hallo.
Es ist eine Schule
für Kinder mit Behinderung.
Hier hat Emil
Kameraden und Freunde gefunden.
# Guata Tag, guata Tag,
liaba Emil.
# Wia goht's, wia staht's?
(Zwei Frauen) # Äs gaht miar guat,
äs gaht miar guat,
# äs gaht miar würkli guat.
(Frau) Emil, wohnst du hier?
Er sagt: "Hier."
Frau Hitz, wohnst du hier?
- Ja.
Ich wohne in diesem Haus.
In diesem Kindergarten hat Emil
praktisch eine 1:1-Betreuung.
Seine Eltern sagen,
er komme sehr gerne hierher
und nehme sehr viel mit.
Es ist aufgeräumt. Alles gut.
Wir gehen zurück
in den Kindergarten.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Ihr hattet einen Neuanfang,
den ihr euch nicht gewünscht habt.
Der Neuanfang wurde euch
durch den Unfall aufgezwungen.
Wir hatten
einen aufgezwungenen Neuanfang. Ja.
Man weiss ja vorher nichts
von einem solchen Schicksalsschlag
oder Ereignis.
Man stellt sich auch nicht vor,
dass so etwas passieren könnte.
Ist das lecker?
- Das wurde uns dreien aufgezwungen.
Wenn Familien von solchen
Schicksalsschlägen betroffen sind,
gehen viele Beziehungen auseinander.
Das war bei euch auch so.
Hättest du dir vorstellen können,
dass es das beeinflusst?
Damals sicher nicht.
Am Anfang hat man gar keine Zeit,
darüber nachzudenken.
Jetzt im Nachhinein sieht man,
dass das jeder anders verarbeitet.
Das ist normal. Ganz klar.
Aber man ist so ...
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Wir waren in einer Blase drin,
in der es nur um Emil ging.
Das Thema Emil war so präsent,
dass alles andere scheissegal war.
Für mich ist nur Emil wichtig.
Er steht im Vordergrund.
Er kann nichts dafür.
Er kann nichts für den Unfall.
Er kann nichts für sein Schicksal.
Er kann auch nichts dafür,
dass wir uns getrennt haben.
Ich bin da für ihn,
das ist klar für mich.
Ja.
Ich mache so viel wie möglich ...
... damit er das Leben
normal geniessen kann.
Wie alle anderen Kinder auch.
Was wünscht ihr euch jetzt
für Emils Zukunft?
Welches Leben?
Dass er weiterhin ein so fröhlicher
und lustiger Bub sein darf.
Dass er seinen Weg gehen darf.
Dass er vielleicht
selber entscheiden darf,
wohin sein Leben führt.
Momentan entscheiden wir das ja
zu einem grossen Teil.
Das braucht er natürlich auch.
Er wird jetzt sechs.
Aber dass er irgendwann sagen darf:
"Ich möchte das und das machen."
Dass er einfach
so cool weitermachen darf.
Ich habe schon oft "cool" gesagt,
aber das passt so gut zu ihm.
Dass er seinen Weg weitergehen darf
und wir ihn dabei begleiten können.
Durch Emils Unfall habe sie gelernt,
jeden Tag so zu nehmen,
wie er kommt, sagt Ladina Kindschi.
Und sie habe auch lernen müssen,
das zu akzeptieren und anzunehmen,
was passiert ist.
Wie geht man
am besten mit einem Neuanfang um,
den einem das Schicksal aufzwingt?
Das will ich mit dem Philosophen
und "SRF Sternstunde"-Moderator
Yves Bossart rausfinden.
Wenn man ein Schicksal wie das
von Ladina und ihrer Familie sieht,
fragt man sich als Philosoph
sicher manchmal,
wie ein Neuanfang in einem
solchen Moment gelingen kann.
Gibt die Philosophie Hinweise darauf?
Es gibt in der antiken Philosophie,
bei der Stoa,
sehr wertvolle Hilfestellungen,
um mit Krisen, Katastrophen
und Schicksalsschlägen umzugehen.
Eigentlich wissen wir,
dass wir krank werden
oder verunfallen können,
dass Menschen sterben und wir selber
irgendwann sterben müssen.
Aber wir verdrängen das.
Und wenn es passiert,
wirft es uns alle aus der Bahn.
Die Stoa, die stoische Philosophie,
ist der Versuch,
so gut es geht
gelassen und ruhig zu bleiben,
um mit diesen Schicksalsschlägen
umgehen zu können.
Wie ein Fels in der Brandung.
Ein Rezept dafür ist:
Wenn man die Dinge, das Leben,
nicht ändern kann,
kann man immer
seine Einstellung dazu ändern.
Das klingt natürlich ...
- Ich wollte sagen ...
Wenn das
krasse Schicksalsschläge sind,
braucht das extrem viel.
Aber es bleibt einem
nichts anderes übrig,
als das Leben neu in Angriff zu
nehmen und den Mut dazu zu haben.
Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen einem durch das Schicksal
aufgezwungenen Neuanfang
und einem, den man selber wählt?
- Das eine ist wie ...
... ein Push-Faktor:
"Etwas treibt mich weg."
Z.B. von der Heimat,
wie gerade in der Ukraine,
oder von seinem alten Leben -
als gesunder Mensch,
mit einem gesunden Körper -
oder in einer Beziehung.
Es wird einem etwas weggerissen.
Bei
einem selbst gewählten Neuanfang -
Leute die auswandern
oder ein neues Leben anfangen -
gibt es weit weg ein Ideal,
das einen anzieht.
Wenn man daran denkt,
zieht es einen dorthin.
Das hat etwas extrem Schönes.
Hermann Hesse sagte: "Jedem Anfang
wohnt ein Zauber inne."
Das ist wirklich so.
Diese Fähigkeit,
sich neu erfinden zu können,
nennt die Philosophin Hannah Arendt
Natalität.
Man könnte es Geburtlichkeit nennen,
im Vergleich zur Mortalität.
Wir sind alle sterblich,
werden aber auch irgendwann geboren.
Wir können immer wieder
eine neue Geburt einleiten.
Im metaphorischen Sinne.
Wir können ein Projekt starten,
ein Ziel verfolgen
oder uns selber neu erfinden.
- Darüber habe ich immer gelächelt.
Das ist ja im Trend,
sich neu zu erfinden.
Aber ich bin ja immer die Gleiche.
Ich komme mit meinem ganzen Gepäck.
Wie erfinde ich mich neu?
Wie würde man das machen?
- Eine Idee ist der Versuch,
eine Situation so zu erleben,
als wäre es das erste Mal.
Oder eine Person so anzusehen, als
würde man sie zum ersten Mal sehen.
Das ist ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Aber man kann das manchmal,
wenn man z.B. ...
... in ein fremdes Land geht,
wieder in die Schweiz kommt
und die alten Orte - das eigene
Zuhause - mit neuen Augen sieht.
Sich etwas Fremdem,
etwas anderem auszusetzen,
schenkt uns einen neuen Blick
auf das Eigene und Vertraute.
Das verändert uns dann auch selber.
Ich glaube sowieso,
sich Fremdem auszusetzen
und Begegnungen mit Andersdenkenden,
mit anderen Leben zu suchen ...
Manchmal entdecken wir im Fremden
einen Teil von uns selbst
und werden dadurch
erst zu uns selbst.
Indem wir sozusagen
aus der Komfortzone rausgehen.
Ein Neuanfang, den man selbst sucht,
ist häufig
auch ein Entscheid gegen anderes.
Du hast gesagt,
man müsse loslassen können.
Es ist einem ja nicht immer klar,
in welche Richtung es geht.
Liebe ist das beste Beispiel dafür.
- Ja.
Es gibt schöne Studien,
die aufzeigen ...
Die Persönlichkeit wird schon
sehr früh in unserem Leben geformt.
Durch die Genetik, unsere Eltern,
während der ersten paar Lebensjahre
und noch etwas in der Pubertät.
Dann ist es stabil.
Die grössten Veränderungen
finden dann statt,
wenn man den Partner
oder die Partnerin wechselt.
Wenn man neue Beziehungen eingeht.
Das stimmt also insofern.
Wir sind nicht so veränderbar,
aber wenn, dann durch Beziehungen.
Das zeigt,
wie stark wir Beziehungswesen sind,
und wie stark auch andere mich zu
dem machen, was ich im Moment bin.
Danke, Yves Bossart,
das ist die perfekte Überleitung.
Jetzt
kommt die Geschichte einer Liebe,
die wirklich
fast alles verändert hat.
Zwei Frauen - eine grosse Liebe:
Sarah Schädeli und Jasmin Stettler.
Mitten im Leben
haben sie sich gefunden.
Eine Liebe so gross,
dass sich beide entscheiden,
mit langjährig aufgebauten
Beziehungen zu brechen
und sämtliche
gesellschaftliche Normen zu sprengen.
Sarah Schädeli
führte bis vor vier Jahren
ein komplett anderes Leben.
Als Bäuerin, Ehefrau und Mutter.
Es war eine super Zeit auf dem Hof.
Ich hätte das nicht anders gewollt.
Z.B. wie die Kinder
aufwachsen konnten usw.
Wir hatten den Hof
wirklich als Familie.
Wenn es so gut ist,
überlegt man sich nicht,
dass es
auch mal schlechter sein könnte.
Die Wende kommt, als Sarah Schädeli
zufällig Jasmin Stettler kennenlernt.
Liebe auf den zweiten Blick
sei es gewesen.
Doch dann umso heftiger.
Schädeli entscheidet sich,
Mann und Hof zu verlassen.
Die Kinder bleiben auf dem Betrieb,
in engem Kontakt mit der Mutter.
Wir begleiten Sarah Schädeli
zu ihren Eltern.
Sie wohnen direkt neben dem Bauernhof
ihres ehemaligen Mannes.
Happy Birthday.
- Merci.
Alles Gute zum Geburtstag.
- Danke.
Merci, Sarah. Danke.
- Hallo.- Hallo, Sarah.
Schädelis Vater hat Geburtstag.
Auch zwei ihrer Kinder
sind am Fest mit dabei.
Die älteste Tochter
ist zurzeit im Ausland.
Was die gelernte Bäuerin
nicht berechnet hatte:
Die Trennung hat
massive finanzielle Konsequenzen.
Es hat mich
immer sehr viel Kraft gekostet,
all das Emotionale ...
Sicherzustellen, dass
man den Kindern gerecht wird ...
Es war mir ja so wichtig,
dass es ihnen dabei gutgeht.
Dann sollte man sich noch
ums Rechtliche kümmern,
von dem man selber ... ja ...
... nicht wirklich
eine grosse Ahnung hat.
Eigentlich ging ich davon aus,
weil man zusammen
etwas erarbeitet hat ...
Ich habe viel Arbeit dazu geleistet.
So konnten wir
den Hof auch weiterbringen.
Für mich war klar,
dass das aufgeteilt wird.
Nicht so in der Landwirtschaft.
Der Hof ist das eigentliche Vermögen
der Bauern und gehört meist dem Mann.
Gibt es
keine vertragliche Absicherung,
geht die Frau leer aus.
So war es auch bei Sarah Schädeli.
Die Eltern erinnern sich, wie
verzweifelt die Tochter damals war:
Ich erinnere mich,
ich war im Keller.
Und als ich nach oben kam,
war sie in Tränen aufgelöst
und sagte: "Ich kriege nichts."
Das war ein Schock.
"Ich kriege nichts."
Als ich mitkriegte, dass eine Frau,
die 16 Jahre da drüben war,
nichts, aber wirklich gar nichts
zugute hatte ...
Ich konnte das fast nicht glauben.
Aber es war effektiv so.
Es war so emotional.
Man denkt: "Ich habe all die Jahre
mein Bestes gegeben."
Und plötzlich hat man nichts mehr.
Ich kann das gar nicht ...
Ich kann das nicht fassen.
Mit 42 Jahren muss Sarah Schädeli -
der grossen Liebe wegen -
praktisch bei null wieder anfangen.
Nach drei Monaten
blieben mir noch 2'500 Fr.
Ich wusste,
dass ich eine Stelle brauchte,
da sonst meine Existenz
zugrunde gehen würde,
respektive,
dass ich dann aufs Sozialamt müsste.
Ich musste mich dem normalen
Bewerbungsprozess stellen.
Ich bewarb mich
quasi wieder auf dem freien Markt.
Ich suchte kaufmännische Stellen.
Also in meinem angestammten Bereich.
Eigentlich wäre ich gerne zurück
in die Versicherungsbranche.
Ich hatte bei verschiedenen
Versicherungsbrokern gearbeitet.
Mir gefiel das sehr.
Aber schlussendlich war ich froh,
überhaupt etwas zu finden.
Mittendrin das Leben umkrempeln
und neu anfangen -
für eine gemeinsame Zukunft
nehmen Sarah Schädeli
und Jasmin Stettler in Kauf,
dass sich langjährige Freunde
von ihnen abwenden
und dass ihr Leben künftig
ausserhalb der gesellschaftlichen
Konvention stattfindet.
Hier treffe ich Sarah Schädeli
an einem anderen Ort,
auf dem Schüpberg,
aber immer noch mit derselben Frau,
mit Jasmin Stettler.
Ihr beiden habt mir das Du angeboten,
das nehme ich gerne an.
Wenn man das sieht, merkt man,
wie schwierig der Neuanfang war.
In welchem Moment hast du gemerkt,
dass nichts daran vorbeiführt?
Ja, das ist ...
In mir drin sah ich unseren Weg
eigentlich schon immer.
Mit uns zwei. Es ist ...
- Von Anfang an?
Ja. Nach dem ersten Kuss.
Nach dem ersten Kuss
war das wie klar.
Schon als wir uns schrieben,
habe ich mich ihr anvertraut.
Du warst ja auch
mit einem Mann zusammen.- Genau.
Ja.
Ihr habt euch
als Freundinnen gekannt.
Genau.
Es fing alles mit dem Hund an.
Mein damaliger Partner
wünschte sich einen Hund.
Wir lebten damals im Tessin
und hatten ein Restaurant.
Er fand, es sei der richtige Ort.
Der Moment, um einen Hund zu haben.
Dann kamen wir
durch eine Empfehlung auf den Hof,
auf dem Sarah die Hunde züchtete.
Du hast die Hunde gezüchtet
und du hast einen Hund geholt.
Und am Ende
kam etwas ganz anderes dabei raus.
Wie das Leben eben manchmal spielt.
Genau. Etwas Unerwartetes.
Dass man jemanden kennenlernt
und eine Beziehung verlässt,
erleben sehr viele.
Du hast dich in eine Frau verliebt.
Vorher
warst du mit einem Mann zusammen.
Machte es das
schwieriger oder einfacher?
Den Gedanken machte ich mir nie.
Es war einfach Liebe.
Das war einfach die Person.
Es war die Liebe zu Jasmin.
Für mein Umfeld war es ...
* Bellen *
Der Postbote kommt gerade.
- Ja.
Ja, die Post ist da.
- Jetzt musst du aufpassen.
Setz dich mal hin.
Sesshaft sind die beiden Frauen
übrigens erst seit Kurzem wieder:
Bis vor paar Monaten waren sie
mit einem Wohnmobil unterwegs.
Die Post
ist im neuen Zuhause angekommen.
Man kommt nicht
um die Beurteilung von aussen rum,
speziell,
wenn es um einen Neuanfang geht,
Als es damals darum ging,
wie ernst das mit euch war,
war dir dabei bewusst, was der Preis
dafür ist? Was Sarah auch aufgab?
Natürlich.
Das war immer ein zentrales Thema.
Ich weiss nicht, wie viele Stunden
wir anfangs telefonierten
und sie hin- und herschwankte
zwischen "Es geht"
und "Es geht nicht".
Für mich war klar,
dass sie das entscheiden muss.
Sie hatte drei Kinder
und einen Hof, einen Betrieb.
Klar, ich war auch selbstständig,
hatte auch einen Betrieb,
aber für mich war es einfacher.
Wie haben deine Kinder reagiert?
Und wie reagieren sie heute?
Ich denke, ich war
von Anfang an ehrlich mit ihnen.
Eine Tochter sagte dann:
"Mama, jetzt bist du eine Lesbe."
Da fand ich: "Okay, wenn du
diese Schublade brauchen willst ..."
Ja, dieses Schubladendenken
ist nicht so meins.
War es schlimm für sie
und deswegen sagte sie das
oder war es eine Feststellung?
Es war einfach eine Feststellung.
- "Mama ist eine Lesbe."- Ja.
Und ja ... Und ... Und eben ...
Ich sprach auch mit meinem Jüngsten
immer darüber:
"Fühlst du etwas?", "Ist etwas?"
Ich habe sie
auch immer dazu ermuntert,
einfach ihre Gefühle auszudrücken.
Die Frage beim Neuanfang ist:
Was darf man anderen für das zumuten,
was einen selber glücklich macht?
Was müssen andere aushalten?
Schlussendlich ist es schon so:
Dein Ex-Mann und deine Kinder
mussten die Konsequenzen tragen.
Wie viel "Leid" darf man anderen
für das eigene Glück zufügen?
Das ist
eine sehr philosophische Frage.
Darüber
könnten wir stundenlang diskutieren.
Wie hast du das abgewogen?
Je ein Engel und ein Teufel
auf der Schulter,
oder wie auch immer
man das nennen will.
Der Engel sagte: "Unmöglich.
Du bist hier eingebunden."
"Das geht nicht."
Und der Teufel: "Doch, das geht."
"Irgendwo
eröffnen sich dann neue Wege."
Und das mit dem Leid zufügen ...
Du hast deine Kinder
einfach nie zu Opfern gemacht.
Also,
nicht zu Opfern einer Situation.
Durch Aufklärung und Kommunikation
und dadurch,
dass man ihnen
dieses Gefühl gar nicht gab,
dass sie in dieser Situationen
die Armen sind.
Es wurde gezeigt:
"Wir sind für euch da."
Ich glaube, das war die Haltung:
niemanden zum Opfer zu machen.
Das verändert
auch für das Gegenüber sehr viel.
Das wäre etwas, wenn man fragt,
was es für einen Neuanfang braucht:
nicht unbedingt
mit schlechten Gewissen zu sagen
"Sorry, das ist megaschlimm
für dich", sondern ...
... "Wir gehen alle gestärkt
aus der Situation."
Es kann auch ein Gewinn für alle
sein, wenn sich etwas verändert.
Dinge können sich auch so verändern,
dass alle als Gewinner hervorgehen.
Klar ist da eine Familienstruktur,
die jetzt nicht mehr existiert.
Aber das brachte
auch viel Positives mit sich.
Für Leute
in einer ähnlichen Situation,
die sich überlegen
"Neuanfang oder besser nicht?" -
gibt es einen Tipp?
Schwierig.
Man muss immer spüren, was man will.
Man muss rausfinden, was
für einen selbst das Richtige ist.
Der Schritt allein
ist schon eine Challenge.
"Was will ich wirklich?" -
das wissen die wenigsten.
Man muss sich bewusst werden,
wo die Reise hingeht
und was man in seinem Leben will.
Wenn man sein Leben neu aufbaut,
muss man sich bewusst sein,
dass man sich ja immer mitnimmt.
Auch an einen neuen Ort.
Wenn sich
wirklich etwas verändern soll,
muss man bei sich selber anfangen.
Ihr seid ja auch im Coaching tätig:
Was hindert die meisten Leute dran,
einen Neuanfang zu machen?
Kinder und Finanzen.
- Ja. Das ist der Hauptgrund.
Wenn man das Gewohnte verlässt,
kommt viel Unbekanntes auf einen zu.
Oft sind die Kinder der Grund.
Und auch die Frage:
"Wie kann ich mir das leisten?"
"Wie geht es weiter für mich,
wenn ich da raus bin?"
Das ist zentral.
Wie lange braucht es,
bis man wieder auf die Beine kommt,
wenn man bei null anfängt?
Das ist eine spannende Frage.
Wir brauchten rund vier Jahre,
bis wir finanziell
komplett wiederhergestellt waren.
Das hinterlässt eine Lücke,
das ist ganz klar.
Verzicht gehört also auch dazu.
- Ja.
Unser Philosoph Yves Bossart sagte,
eine Liebesbeziehung
sei die grösste Veränderung im Leben.
Könnt ihr das bestätigen?
Das würde ich unterschreiben.
- Ja.
Also. Danke vielmals,
dass wir bei euch auf dem Schüpberg
reinschauen durften.
Alles Gute.
- (Beide) Merci vielmals.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich bin zurück
im Reka-Dorf an der Lenk.
Da, wo seit Kriegsausbruch
ukrainische Flüchtlinge leben.
Ich treffe Vlada wieder.
Sie ist überglücklich:
Ihr Freund Bohdan ist da.
Begleitet werde ich wieder von Mira,
der ukrainischen Dolmetscherin.
Hi, so good to see you, Vlada.
Schön, euch zu sehen.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Es ist kaum zu glauben,
aber hier bin ich.
Wie schwierig war es für dich,
in die Schweiz zu kommen?
Es war ziemlich schwierig.
Ich musste
sämtliche Papiere überprüfen lassen,
Bewilligungen erhalten vom Staat
und v.a. vom Militär,
dass ich
nicht in den Militärdienst muss
und dank des Studienplatzes
an der Fachhochschule
in die Schweiz ausreisen darf.
Ich glaube, so kann ich
meinem Land am besten dienen.
Vlada, wie war es für dich,
als er dann ankam?
Wie hast du dich gefühlt?
Ich bin sehr, sehr glücklich,
dass alles geklappt hat
und er jetzt da ist.
Denkst du, du machst hier
eine Art Neustart in der Schweiz?
Ja,
das Leben hat eine Wende genommen.
Hier bin ich und mache Pläne
für meine Zukunft in der Schweiz.
Ich möchte einen Abschluss machen
und mich spezialisieren.
Ich werde mein Bestes tun,
um diese Chance zu packen.
Das Reka-Dorf
hat sich stark geleert.
Noch knapp 100 Menschen leben hier.
Im Oktober müssen alle
eine Wohnung gefunden haben.
Dann gehört das Feriendorf
wieder den Touristen.
Vladas Mutter ist noch hier
und auch ihre WG-Mitbewohnerin
Natalia Kaminska mit Tochter Alina.
Sie, die vor ein paar Wochen ihren
Sohn in die Schweiz bringen wollte.
Du warst in der Ukraine.
Ist er jetzt hier?
(Mira) Nein.
Er wollte nicht kommen.
- Er wollte nicht kommen?
Er hat mir gesagt, er wolle auf
jeden Fall in der Ukraine bleiben.
Er werde nicht
mit mir in die Schweiz kommen.
Wie war das für dich?
- Es war sehr schwierig.
Doch es ist sein Leben, seine Wahl.
Für mich
war es physisch und psychisch
eine sehr anstrengende Reise.
Natalia Kaminskas Sohn
hat sich gegen seine Mutter
und für den ukrainischen
Militärdienst entschieden.
Für Natalia ist im Moment unklar,
wie es für sie und ihre
14-jährige Tochter Alina weitergeht.
Glaubst du, dass die Menschen hier,
wie z.B. Natalia,
die etwas hin- und hergerissen ist,
überhaupt einen Neuanfang machen
können in einer solchen Situation?
Wenn man damit aufhört,
eine Zukunft zu planen ...
... ist das sinnlos.
Ich bin auch der Meinung,
dass man versuchen muss ...
Also, ich bin schon optimistisch,
aber es ist sehr schwierig,
in dieser Situation etwas zu planen.
Man muss es versuchen.
Wir müssen weitermachen.
Das ist unsere Aufgabe.
Wir Menschen müssen weitermachen.
Mira sagt mir, was ihr extrem helfe
in dieser schwierigen Situation,
sei die Hilfsbereitschaft
der Bevölkerung,
die sie hier in der Schweiz
stark spüre.
Nebst dem Krieg in der Ukraine
war die Pandemie
eine andere grosse Herausforderung,
mit der
wir uns alle beschäftigen mussten.
In der Schweiz
waren nicht alle damit zufrieden,
wie wir das
in unserem Land gemeistert haben.
Diese Leute fanden, es brauche
einen gesellschaftlichen Neuanfang.
Einer davon ist Coronamassnahmen-
gegner Roland Schätti,
der quasi über Nacht
zum Freiheitstrychler wurde.
Mein "Rec."-Kollege Donat war während
der Pandemie mit ihm unterwegs.
Wie ticken Freiheitstrychler?
Das will ich rausfinden.
Darum
fahre ich vom Nebel in die Sonne,
ins Toggenburg zu Roli und Bea.
Sie sind ein Paar und gehören zum
Kern der harten Freiheitstrychler.
An meinen Schultern
hängt ein Sack voller Zweifel.
Haben die Freiheitstrychler
nicht schon genug
oder sogar zu viel mediale Präsenz?
Oder lohnt es sich genau darum,
wegen der grossen Ausstrahlungskraft,
der Blick hinter die Kulissen?
Nicht zuletzt
ist es eine Suche nach Dialog.
Etwas kann ich vorwegnehmen:
Ich bin ganz anderer Meinung als sie.
Es war lange unsicher,
ob ich als SRF-Reporter
in den inneren Kreis
der Freiheitstrychler komme.
Ihr Vertrauen in klassische Medien
ist so gross wie ein Virus.
Roli sieht das zum Glück entspannt.
Ein gemeinsames Mittagessen und
ein Funken gegenseitiger Sympathie
ist die Grundlage dieser Reportage.
Das hier war meine Droge.
- Was ist das?
Hustensirup.
Drogen gegen oder für was?
- Für/gegen Husten.
Aha. Hast du einen Husten?
- Ja, ich war ...
... letzten Monat auch etwas krank,
aber jetzt ist gut.
Hast du getestet?
- Was ist das?
Den teste ich täglich viermal.
Machst du nie Coronatests?
* Lachen *
Hast du schon mal einen gemacht?
- Sicher nicht.
Geht's noch? Wofür?
So gibst du das Virus einfach weiter.
- Welches Virus?
Ei, ei, ei. Roli, Roli, Roli.
Bea und Roli
sind seit sechs Jahren ein Paar.
Sie ist 48 und Fachfrau Logistik.
Er ist 55, diplomierter Landwirt
und Reisecarchauffeur.
Beide haben vier Kinder
aus ehemaligen Beziehungen
im Alter zwischen 16 und 30.
Sie zählen zum harten Kern
der Freiheitstrychler.
Bea kümmert sich um die Finanzen,
Roli plant und orchestriert Demos.
Wie kamst du zum Trycheln
bzw. zu den Freiheitstrychlern?
Ich hatte einen Kunden, der fragte,
ob ich im April mit nach Rapperswil
an die Kundgebung komme.
Ich war bis dahin
noch nie an einer Kundgebung.
Da kriegte ich
wirklich feuchte Augen.
Das fuhr mir ein.
- Was heisst das?
Es übermannte mich
wirklich emotional.
Nach Rappi kam ich nach Hause
und bestellte
noch in derselben Woche Trycheln.
Um Trycheln zu bauen.
Was hast du
für die zwei Glocken bezahlt?
4'650 Fr.
Freiheit gibt es nicht gratis.
Zum Abendessen
kommen zwei von Rolis Söhnen dazu.
Beide sind gegen Corona geimpft.
Statt der Pandemie sprichst du
von der Plandemie.- Richtig.
Aber was ich sagen will ...
Wenn wirklich
ein Plan dahintersteht ...
... wenn ich dann
noch auf dem Sofa liegenbleibe
und nicht aufstehe und hinterfrage,
was da abgeht ...
... weiss ich nicht ...
Dann habe ich ...
Dann ging ich vergebens zehn Jahre
zur Schule und in die Lehre.
Meine Meinung dazu ist ...
Ich bin geimpft.
Und zwar,
weil ich in die Ferien wollte.
Warum sollst du dich impfen lassen?
Wegen deiner Gesundheit.
Und um Leute nicht einzuschränken.
Wenn du positiv bist,
bist du positiv.
Ich kann dich trotzdem umarmen.
- Ja.
Muss ich Angst vor dir haben?
Vor dem Virus und dessen Folgen.
Ich habe keine Angst
vor einem Virus.
Oder wegen der anderen.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Freiheit.
Andere ...
- ... die du anstecken könntest.
Ja, das wird interessant morgen.
Es wissen weit nicht alle im Car ...
... dass wir
jemanden wie dich dabeihaben.
Sie werden nicht erfreut sein.
- Doch. Ich hole die schon runter.
Nicht alle.
Du kommst morgen drunter.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht.
Guten Morgen zusammen.
Steigt direkt ein.
Morgen. Das Gepäck kommt unten rein.
- Ja, einladen bitte.
Schönen guten Morgen miteinander.
Das ist der Impfbus nach Genf.
* Lachen *
Guido ist hier, Esther ist hier ...
Silvia?- Ja.
Wir haben Besuch.
Ihr seht es:
Donat ist hier, von ...
Soll ich sagen, von welchem Medium?
- Ja, klar.
Soll ich?
- Ja, ja.- Schweizer Fernsehen.
* Applaus *
Ah, schau, Applaus.
Wirklich.
* Fröhliche Ländlermusik *
Was sagt dein näheres Umfeld dazu,
dass du
bei den Freiheitstrychlern bist?
Meine eigene Familie
steht mittlerweile hinter mir.
Mein Mann ...
Meine Kinder schämten sich etwas.
Ja, das gehört ein bisschen dazu.
Aber mein Mann ist auch dabei.
Und meine Eltern und mein Bruder ...
V.a. meine Eltern ...
... verstehen das gar nicht.
Was sagen sie Ihnen?
Mein Vater meinte,
ich müsse in eine Psychiatrie.
Ich sei total durchgeknallt.
Ich gehe meinen Weg
und fühle mich wohl.
Ich fühle mich
richtig wohl bei den Trychlern.
# Friede, Freiheit,
das Volk ist souverän.
Hey.
- Lasst bitte die Scheibe runter.
Rund um mich Andersdenkende.
Kein einfaches Gefühl.
Sich unverstanden zu fühlen
tut weh.
So wie mir heute, geht es den
Freiheitstrychlern wohl im Alltag.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Es ist Mitte November.
In zwei Wochen stimmt die Schweiz zum
zweiten Mal über das Covid-Gesetz ab.
Für die Demo in Genf schlossen sich
verschiedene Gruppierungen zusammen.
Die Organisatoren
haben die Freiheitstrychler angefragt
und wissen um ihre Beliebtheit
bei den Massnahmenkritikern.
Ich bin etwas nervös,
aber das ist normal.
Das sind schon viele Leute.
* Lautes Glockenläuten *
* Jauchzer *
* Intensiveres Glockenläuten *
* Jubel und Applaus *
Wahnsinn. Das ist emotional.
Ich bin extrem stolz.
Die Leute auf der Strasse sind geil.
Wie heute habe ich das
noch nie erlebt. Hammer.
* Energetische Musik *
Das
sind die Welschen Freiheitstrychler.
Auf das nächste Mal.
- Endlich Feierabend.
Aber ich habe mich zu früh gefreut.
1 Std. später merken sie,
dass sie
neben dem Gebäude der WHO stehen.
Also, sie meinen, es sei die WHO.
Effektiv ist es der Sitz
des UNO-Hochkommissariats
für Menschenrechte.
* Lautes Glockenläuten *
Die 24 Std. mit den
Freiheitstrychlern sind abgelaufen.
Ich fühle mich
wie von einem Car überrollt.
Im Zug nach Hause lasse ich mir
alles durch den Kopf gehen.
In meinen Augen
sind die Freiheitstrychler
eine wild durchmischte Gruppe
mit einem gemeinsamen Nenner:
Die Angst, dass eine Elite
die Pandemie inszeniert
und uns nach Strich und Faden
manipuliert.
Unter Gleichgesinnten
und in digitalen Echokammern
finden sie Antworten,
Verständnis und Zugehörigkeit.
Weder sie noch ich haben nach dieser
Begegnung die Meinung geändert.
Aber wir haben uns zusammen an den
Tisch gesetzt und darüber gesprochen.
Das ist und bleibt wichtig.
* Unruhige Klaviermusik *
Entschuldigung,
wir kommen mit laufender Kamera.
Wow. Roland.
- Mona Vetsch.
Duzen wir uns? Freut mich.
- Gerne.
Wo sind deine Trycheln?
Jetzt,
wo man sie nicht mehr so oft braucht?
Geht es in den Estrich?
- Nicht ganz.
Hier steht schon die Erste.
- Ja. Das ist die unserer Tochter.
Sie trychelt zwar noch nicht,
aber das kommt noch.
Und dort ist mein neuer Satz.
Ein neuer Satz?
- Ja, der alte ...
Also, "alt", den von letztem Jahr
habe ich verkauft.
Wieso?
- Um abzuschliessen.
Um abzuschliessen.
Letztes Jahr
lief zu viel mit den Trychlern.
Um für mich selber
damit abzuschliessen,
habe ich sie verkauft
und einen neuen Satz gekauft.
Als Neuanfang.
Noch während der Pandemie
zerstritten sich
die Freiheitstrychler untereinander.
Anfangs Jahr kam es zur Spaltung.
Der Vorwurf an Roland Schätti:
Er habe sich
nicht an Abmachungen gehalten
und u.a. Medienauftritte im Namen
der Freiheitstrychler gemacht,
die nicht abgesprochen waren.
Du bist eigentlich ja angetreten,
um zu zeigen, wie es geht.
Wie man zusammensteht,
wie Miteinander geht.
Aber ihr habt es nicht mal
zwei Jahre richtig geschafft.
Ja.
- Wie hast du das erlebt?
Ich hatte schon grosse Tiefs,
das ist so.
Ich bin jemand,
der umfällt, kurz liegenbleibt
und dann wieder aufsteht
und weitergeht.
Die Quintessenz ist ja, dass wir
eine neue Gruppierung haben:
Ostschweiz und Zürich Oberland.
Klein und fein.
Auch Freiheitstrychler?
Nicht
unter dem Namen Freiheitstrychler,
das ist uns ja untersagt.
Wir haben eigene Hemden
und fast alle
haben mittlerweile auch Trycheln.
Wir stehen in den Startlöchern.
Der Herbst kann kommen.
Du hast das Wort selbst genannt:
Neuanfang.
Für dich ist das ein Neuanfang.
- Ja.
Aber mit den Freiheitstrychlern
gab es schon eine erste Wegscheidung.
Du bist abgebogen.
Wo geht es jetzt hin?
- Das frage ich mich auch.
Schauen wir doch mal.
- Was ich feststelle:
Roland Schätti und sein Umfeld
sind der festen Überzeugung,
dass der Staat
uns Bürgerinnen und Bürger
im Krisenfall nicht mehr
gut genug versorgen könnte.
Was ist das, was du jetzt öffnest?
Das ist mein Keller.
Ja.
- Du darfst ihn dir ansehen.
Du hast einen Notvorrat eingerichtet.
Ja, also die Weinflaschen nicht.
Die zählen
nicht unbedingt zum Notfallvorrat.
Ja, schau. Das ist eine Vormischung:
Weizen-Dinkel-Roggen.
Weizen-Roggen-Dinkel,
jeweils ein Drittel. Das ist Weizen.
Zucker und Salz in kleinen Mengen.
Wirklich einfach so ...
Und Strom? Das ist momentan
das Wahrscheinlichste.
Der Bundesrat hat ja informiert,
dass wir wegen des Ukrainekonflikts
auf einen Stromengpass hinsteuern.
Was ist das?
- Ein Altstromaggregat.
Da kann man die Liegenschaft
direkt anhängen.- Wie läuft das?
Mit Diesel.
- Aha.
Aber den hast du ja auch nicht mehr.
- Wer sagt das?
Ich.
Dem ist nicht so,
das kann ich dir sagen.
"Dem ist nicht so" -
d.h., du hast
irgendwo einen grossen Dieselvorrat.
Aber nicht hier.
Hier habe ich keinen Platz.
Okay. Du ... Ja.
- Jetzt bist du baff. Mona baff.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
in eine Prepper-Wohnung reinzukommen.
Wenn du sagst, ich sei ein Prepper:
Das bin ich gerne.
Ich habe wenigstens vorgesorgt.
Ihr könntet
mehr als ein Jahr davon leben?- Ja.
Hast du das durchgerechnet?
- So Handgelenk mal Pi, ja.
Gibt es online Anleitungen dafür?
- Ja, das sind die Empfehlungen.
Da kommt man relativ schnell
in die Prepper-Szene,
wenn man das googelt.
Man nimmt so das raus,
was für einen selber stimmt.
Nicht im eigenen Garten,
sondern ausserhalb
hätten sie Nahrungsmittel angebaut.
Z.B. auf einem Kartoffelacker,
wo sie gerade ernten würden.
Roland Schätti erklärt mir,
er und seine Leute
wollten bereit sein.
Aber wofür genau und wie weit
das geht, verstehe ich noch nicht.
Bei diesen Vorbereitungen
stellt sich als letzte Frage:
Muss man sich auch wehren können?
- Ja.
Muss man sich bewaffnen?
- Äh ...
Bist du bewaffnet?
- Ja, ganz klar.
Noch nicht so lange.
- Was heisst das?
Äh ... Ich habe ... Äh ...
Wir trainieren regelmässig
mit Kurzwaffen.
Mit Langwaffen
ist es relativ schwierig.
Damit
kann man nicht überall trainieren.
Aber mit Kurzwaffen,
sprich Faustfeuerwaffen -
9mm oder die Kleinkaliber ...
Wenn wir während der Pandemie
etwas erlebt haben,
ist das eine unglaubliche Trennung
der Gesellschaft.
Und ein Ton, der extrem
an Aggression zugenommen hat.
Wenn du mir jetzt sagst,
dass ihr schiessen trainiert ...
Das ist nicht unbedingt
das beste Zeichen, oder?
Müssen wir damit rechnen ...
- Okay.
Du konfrontierst mich
jetzt natürlich ein Stück weit.
Das ist auch legitim.
Aber ich darf meine Haltung
legitim vertreten.
Ich bin nicht aggressiv unterwegs.
Das hat man auch bei
den Freiheitstrychlern gesehen,
z.B. bei der Kundgebung.
Ich war
immer deeskalierend unterwegs.
Ich war auch oft ohne Trychel, dafür
mit der gelben Weste unterwegs.
Aber sind alle so in dieser Gruppe?
- Nein, sicher nicht.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
- Eben.
Es gibt verschiedenste Kostgänger
in unserer Gesellschaft.
Bis hierhin kann man es ja
noch "kurios-amüsant" finden.
Aber sobald es um Waffen geht,
wird es mir ein bisschen anders.
Sicher?
- Ja. Sorry.
Wenn man etwas weiss, dann ist es:
Je mehr Waffen es hat,
desto mehr passiert.
Das ist nicht erstaunlich.
Amerika ist das Beispiel.
Aber wenn du sagst,
du müsstest dich verteidigen,
frage ich mich: "Gegen wen oder was?"
Wer bedroht dich?
Jetzt
bedroht mich eigentlich niemand.
Es ist auch ein Hobby,
das man brauchen kann.
Das
ist eine Tradition in der Schweiz.
Wir haben so viele Schützenvereine.
Wir schätzen es,
dass man dem Hobby nachgehen kann.
Das ist schön
und ich finde das auch sinnvoll.
Man kann das als Hobby machen,
aber im schlimmsten Falle
kann man es zur Landes-
oder Selbstverteidigung brauchen.
Roland Schätti
weicht meiner Frage aus.
Eine klare Antwort,
von wem er sich bedroht fühlt,
erhalte ich bis am Schluss nicht.
Offenbar hat er sich
ein Krisenszenario zurechtgelegt,
das sein Handeln rechtfertigt
und zum Ziel hat,
für sich selber zu sorgen
und unabhängig vom Staat zu sein.
Yves Bossart, Philosoph, Moderator
der "Sternstunde Philosophie".
Es gibt Menschen, die nicht nur von
einem persönlichen Neuanfang träumen,
sondern von einem gesellschaftlichen.
Die Freiheitstrychler
sind nur ein Beispiel.
Was ist der grösste Unterschied?
Dass man nicht allein ist
bei einem sozialen Neuanfang.
Das macht es nicht einfacher, oder?
Alle anderen bzw. eine
kritische Masse muss auch mitziehen,
wenn man findet,
es laufe etwas grundlegend falsch
in unserer Gesellschaft.
Letztlich ist ja der Anspruch,
dass unsere Gesellschaft
sich verändern muss ...
Die gehört zu meinem Leben dazu.
Vieles
ist durch die Gesellschaft bestimmt:
durch Gesetze,
Vorschriften, Kultur usw.
Was ist der Grund oder der Ursprung
für dieses Gefühl,
die Gesellschaft verändern,
einen Neuanfang zu wollen?
Dass wir in die falsche Richtung
gehen. Z.B. die Klim...
Ein Ungerechtigkeitsempfinden?
- Richtig.
Oder dass das nicht nachhaltig ist,
wir so nicht weitermachen können.
Z.B. die Klimabewegung, die findet,
wir beuten unseren Planeten aus
und schaden
den zukünftigen Generationen.
Was braucht es, damit so ein Anstoss
in einen Neuanfang mündet?
Heutzutage, wo grosse Probleme
auf die Menschheit warten ...
Die sind ja globaler Natur:
Klimawandel, Migration ...
Auch die Digitalisierung.
Viele der Probleme können wir
nur als gesamte Menschheit lösen.
Das macht es natürlich schwierig.
Man muss nicht nur alle Schweizer,
sondern die ganze Welt überzeugen.
Man muss eine Art finden,
um miteinander
für globale Gerechtigkeit zu sorgen.
Und Institutionen zu schaffen,
die das durchsetzen und binden.
Die Gefahr ist,
dass man sich zurücklehnt
und andere erst mal anfangen lässt.
"Ich bin nicht der Dumme,
der vorangeht."
Dann leben alle noch nach dem alten
System und profitieren davon.
Das sind die grossen
Herausforderungen der heutigen Zeit.
Wir müssen als Menschheit
einen Weg finden,
um nachhaltig zu leben
und aus Einsicht zu handeln.
Auch wenn das so schwierig ist,
weil wir den Leidensdruck
noch nicht so stark spüren.
Danke vielmals, Yves Bossart.
Das Stichwort Klimajungend
ist gefallen.
Die hat genau so angefangen:
Junge Menschen mit demselben Anspruch
fanden zusammen.
Sie sagten, es brauche
einen gesellschaftlichen Neuanfang.
Rauf mit den Klimazielen,
runter mit dem CO2!
Zehntausende, v.a. junge Menschen,
gehen fürs Klima auf die Strasse.
Einer, der die Massen mobilisiert:
Jonas Kampus, 17-jähriger Gymnasiast.
Wir müssen weitermachen
und das ganze Leben kämpfen,
um das zu schaffen.
Eine solche Jugendbewegung gab es
seit den 1980er-Jahren nicht mehr.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, Klimawandel stopp!
Eine Bewegung, die den Planeten
vor dem Kollaps retten will.
Nur 100 globale Konzerne
sind für 70 %
aller CO2-Emissionen verantwortlich.
Gazprom ...
* Buhrufe *
Gazprom, ExxonMobil,
Chevron, BP, Shell, Glencore
und noch 94 weitere.
Da macht es wohl wenig Sinn,
zu behaupten,
wir könnten die Klimakrise mit
unserem Konsumverhalten überwinden.
Der blutjunge Jonas Kampus wird
zu einem der Köpfe der Klimabewegung.
Ich hatte kurz
fast kein Blut mehr im Kopf.
Hast du was gegessen?
- Ein Brötchen, ja.
Die Eltern sorgen sich um ihren Sohn.
Wir verfolgen Zeitungen,
Onlinemedien usw. und achten darauf,
dass er nicht zu stark
unter die Räder kommt.
Er ist mit seinem Namen bekannt.
Und da gibt es
einige negative Kommentare.
Man muss darauf achten,
dass er
nicht zu viel Aufmerksamkeit kriegt.
Was wollen die Jungen erreichen?
Sind das realistische Ziele?
Die jungen Aktivisten
stellen sich bei Radio 1
den kritischen Fragen
von Roger Schawinski.
Wir nehmen die Sendung
nach der Demo am Samstagabend auf.
Drei der Organisatoren sind bei mir.
Wenn man radikale Forderungen
stellt, von denen man weiss,
sie können
nicht umgesetzt werden ...
Die Zahl 2030 haben wir
uns nicht einfach so erdacht.
Wir alle haben uns eingehend
mit dem letzten Spezialbericht des
Weltklimarates auseinandergesetzt.
Der zeigt einfach,
dass die Emissionen bis 2050
auf Nettonull runter müssen.
Bis 2050.
- Auf der ganzen Welt.
Die Schweiz ist ein Industrieland.
D.h., sie muss früher runter.
Wir
gingen da klar wissenschaftlich vor.
Wir sind auch im Dialog
mit Klimawissenschaftlern.
Wie gross ist die Chance,
dass das passiert?
Wie gross schätzt du die Chance ein,
dass wir überleben?
Gegenfragen sind immer gut,
wenn man keine guten Antworten hat.
Ich frage euch, ob realitätsfremde
Gedanken klug seien,
oder ob ihr eher realistischere
Szenarien aufzeigen müsstet.
Ist das das Privileg
von euch Jugendlichen?
Ihr müsst euch nicht
um die Realisierung kümmern?
Ja, wir müssen uns in dem Sinne
nicht um die Realisierung kümmern,
weil wir dafür Politiker
in unserem Parlament haben,
die eine Ahnung davon haben sollten.
Aber Fakt ist, dass wir diese Krise
haben und jetzt etwas machen müssen.
Jonas Kampus und eine Gruppe
von Klimaaktivistinnen
auf dem Weg nach Davos.
Die Gymischüler aus Wetzikon
wollen am Weltwirtschaftsforum
für den Klimaschutz demonstrieren.
Jonas
muss noch eine Rede vorbereiten.
Ich dachte, dass ich am Anfang
noch mal ins Publikum rufe:
What do we want?
- (Beide) Climate justice!
When do we want it?
- Now!
Ohne brutalste
und immer härtere Ausbeutung
hätte die Klimakrise
nie dieses Ausmass erreichen können.
Wir schreiben die Rede fürs WEF.
Ich wurde gestern
um 20 Uhr dafür angefragt.
Inspiriert wird die Klimajugend
von der 16-jährigen Greta Thunberg.
Die Ikone der Klimabewegung
ist auch am WEF.
Mit ihren Auftritten
zwingt sie Politik und Wirtschaft,
sich mit dem Thema Klima
zu beschäftigen.
Was wollen Sie
den Mächtigen hier mitteilen?
Dass sie versagt haben.
Und dass wir keine Zukunft haben,
wenn wir
die Klimakrise jetzt nicht packen.
Warum sind Sie so bestimmt?
Würde ich es nicht machen,
würde ich mich schlecht fühlen.
Ich will zurückschauen
und sagen können:
"Ich habe alles versucht."
Jonas!
Wir sind hier, wir sind laut,
weil man uns die Zukunft klaut!
Wir werden nicht mehr ruhen,
bis wir wieder eine Zukunft haben.
Gemeinsam können wir das erreichen,
wofür wir alle kämpfen.
* Jubel *
Im Alter von 17 Jahren
stellt Jonas Kampus mit Gleichge-
sinnten eine Bewegung auf die Beine,
die die Schweizer Jugend bewegt.
Wir haben erst gerade angefangen,
einen Riesenwirbel zu machen.
Wir werden weiterhin
auf unsere Forderungen bestehen.
Die müssen erreicht werden,
sonst haben wir keine Zukunft mehr.
Wir machen so lange weiter,
bis wir das erreichen.
Diese Aufnahmen der Klimajugend,
das war vor drei Jahren, 2019.
Jetzt sitzt der junge Mann bei uns,
den wir da kennenlernten.
Herzlich willkommen, Jonas Kampus.
Auch bei uns
ist die "Next Generation".
Sie ist wirklich noch jugendlich
und aktiv fürs Klima.
Sie ist 15:
Ella Frei, Gymischülerin aus Luzern.
Wie du dich engagierst,
darüber reden wir gleich.
Auch bei uns ist Roland Schätti,
den wir vorher kennenlernten:
Er ist ehemaliger Freiheitstrychler.
Wir bringen
soziale Protestbewegungen zusammen,
die beide in den letzten Jahren
für viele Schlagzeilen gesorgt haben.
Wir wollen rausfinden:
Habt ihr nur Differenzen
oder gibt es auch Gemeinsamkeiten?
Jonas, wir fangen bei dir an.
Wir sagten, wir würden uns duzen.
Vor drei Jahren
warst du voll im Fieber.
Ihr wart auf einem Allzeithoch.
Dann ging es gefühlt
etwas bachab mit der Klimajungend.
Wo steht ihr heute?
Wir stehen
schon an einem anderen Punkt.
Wir haben
zwei Jahre Pandemie hinter uns,
den Ukrainekrieg, der tobt ...
- Brach euch die Pandemie das Genick?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Aber: Wir mussten uns
völlig neu orientieren.
Für eine soziale Bewegungen
gibt es nur die Strasse.
Dort wo Menschen zusammenkommen.
Das sieht man im "DOK"-Film
auch gut.
Ich sagte dort euphorisch:
"Wir müssen einfach weiterkämpfen."
"Das ganze Leben lang."
- Ja, das ist das, was wir ...
Das spürten die 100'000 Menschen
auf der Strasse alle.
Das war nicht mehr möglich.
Es ist schwierig,
das wieder so hinzukriegen.
Aber wir versuchen es
und es gelingt uns auch.
Aber natürlich: Unser Ziel ist,
global die 1,5-°C-Grenze
zu erreichen.
Da sind wir momentan nicht,
aber das ist nicht unsere Schuld.
Es ist wegen der Untätigkeit
von Politik und Wirtschaft,
die weiterhin den fossilen Weg
gehen, nicht handeln
und keinen konsequenten Klimaschutz
betreiben.
Wenn man sagt "Die Klimajugend,
diese Bewegung, die war mal super,
aber eigentlich
hat sie sich jetzt totgelaufen",
was sagst du dann?
Ich würde definitiv sagen,
dass das nicht stimmt.
Wir haben immer noch
viele junge und aktive Menschen.
Es gibt immer wieder neue Menschen,
die sich engagieren.
Wir hatten kürzlich
ein nationales Treffen,
wo Menschen aus der ganzen Schweiz
zusammenkamen.
Das zeigte, dass die Bewegung
nicht am Boden ist.
Wir müssen überlegen, wie wir
weitermachen und darauf reagieren,
wenn Demonstrationen nicht mehr
unser einziges Mittel sind.
Aber tot sind wir definitiv nicht.
- Gutes Stichwort:
Welche Mittel wählt man,
um seinen Anliegen
das nötige Gehör zu verschaffen?
Ein "Rundschau"-Bericht
thematisierte Anfang Sommer,
dass z.T. zu sehr radikalen/illegalen
Mitteln gegriffen wird.
Wir schauen rein.
In Rümlang haben Klimaaktivisten
ein Tanklager besetzt.
(Fahrer) So ein verdammter Mist.
(Mann) Hey. Du bist auf Kamera
und du hast Feierabend.
Es ist das Letzte,
was wir machen können.
Wir haben mit Politikerinnen
und der Wirtschaft gesprochen,
haben legal protestiert -
was sollen wir noch machen?
Wir haben
weder genug Macht noch Geld.
Wir können uns
nur mit unseren Körpern einsetzen.
Bilder einer Autobahnausfahrt
in der Westschweiz,
wo sich Aktivisten
am Boden angeklebt haben.
Oder hier die Besetzung
eines Geländes im Kanton Aargau,
wo der Zementkonzern Holcim
einen Steinbruch vergrössern will.
Weg von hier.
Geht weg oder ich spraye.
Man sah ein paar Beispiele
von Aktionen der Klimajugend,
über die sich Leute massiv aufregten.
Z.T. auch Aktionen,
die euch nahestehen.
Ist eigentlich alles erlaubt,
wenn der Zweck ein "guter" ist?
Die Frage ist eher,
wogegen man sich wehrt.
Wir wehren uns fundamental
gegen die Zerstörung
unserer Lebensgrundlage
durch
die Auswirkungen der Klimakrise.
Die ganz bewusst verursacht wird
durch Erdölkonzerne,
Banken und Rohstoffkonzerne.
Dazu sind natürlich
Mittel wie Demonstrationen,
aber auch
konkrete, effektive Blockaden
wie z.B. des Tanklagers in Rümlang
durchaus erlaubt, sogar notwendig.
Man hat eine Pflicht,
Widerstand zu leisten.
Dann muss man
zu solchen Aktionen greifen.
Man sah das im Einspieler,
als Hanna sagte:
"Wir haben uns
mit Politikerinnen usw. getroffen
und sind auf kein Gehör gestossen."
Man will doch,
dass junge Personen
ein gewisses Vertrauen
zu Autoritätspersonen aufbauen.
Aber das war ein klarer Bruch.
Das führt dazu,
dass man sich hinterfragt.
Das System
arbeitet einfach nicht mit uns.
Es arbeitet klar gegen uns.
Es hat kein Interesse daran,
dass wir die Klimakrise lösen.
Es verschlimmert sie immer weiter.
Hast du das Vertrauen
z.B. in die Regierung verloren?
Genau. Ich habe
ein grosses Vertrauen in Menschen.
Die Menschen
werden jetzt wieder aufstehen.
Ich habe
kein Vertrauen in Regierungen.
Das ist sicher etwas, Roland Schätti,
das euch verbindet.
Du hast das vorher
in ähnlichen Worten gesagt.
Dein Vertrauen in die Regierung
existiert nicht mehr.
Kommt dir das, was du von Jonas
Kampus gehört hast, bekannt vor?
Ja, ganz sicher.
Aber ich beneide euch Jungen heute
ganz und gar nicht.
Mir blutet
fast das Herz ein bisschen,
wenn ich sehe,
was wir, was meine Generation
und die Generation unserer Eltern
euch hinterlässt.
Das frustriert mich auch.
Ich habe diese Woche eine Umfrage
auf Social Media gesehen:
"Wirst du dieses Jahr fliegen?"
51 % sagten Ja.
Das ist eigentlich bedenklich.
Jetzt kann man wieder fliegen
und macht das auch.
Ohne zu hinterfragen,
warum und wieso man das macht.
Interessant. Da frage ich mich:
Warum hast du
gegen Coronamassnahmen protestiert,
anstatt mit der Klimajugend
auf die Strasse zu gehen?
Als Jonas zum ersten Mal auf
die Strasse ging, schlief ich noch.
Er ist seit drei Jahren unterwegs,
seit 2019,
und ich
erst seit Anfang letzten Jahres.
Ich bin relativ spät aufgewacht.
Ich hätte ja nie gedacht, dass ich
mal an eine Kundgebung gehen werde.
Ich musste 55 werden,
um aufzuwachen.
Aber es ist so, ich bin
auch regierungskritisch unterwegs.
Meiner Meinung nach
stimmt das ganze System nicht mehr.
Ich habe
auch noch keine Lösung dafür.
Das ist schwierig.
Wir sind in einem ähnlichen Boot
und versuchen vorwärtszukommen.
Aber wohin das Boot uns führt ...
Frag mich nicht, Mona.
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Zwei "soziale" Protestbewegungen,
die politisch auf der Landkarte
an einem ziemlich anderen Ort stehen.
Aber trotzdem "im gleichen Boot" -
seid ihr damit einverstanden?
Ich glaube, eher weniger.
Ich glaube, wir haben
fundamental andere Vorstellungen.
Gerade der Klimastreik versucht,
viel mit Solidarität zu arbeiten.
Gerade mit weniger privilegierten
Menschen, die z.B. nicht weiss sind,
aber auch
von der Klimakrise betroffen sind.
Bei den Trychlern und Trychlerinnen
ist das weniger der Fall.
Gerade Solidarität mit Risikogruppen
usw.
Ich glaube auch ...
Du hast gesagt, ihr wüsstet
nicht richtig, wo es hingeht.
Da haben wir mehr Vorstellungen.
Der Klimastreik
hat ja den Klimaaktionsplan,
in dem wir viele Massnahmen
aufschreiben, die es braucht,
um die Klimakrise einzudämmen
und das Schlimmste zu verhindern.
Wir machen uns
auch strategisch Gedanken,
wie wir weitermachen möchten.
Da haben wir auch schon Ideen.
Klare Vorstellungen eines Neuanfangs,
das ist unser Thema.
Wie der aussehen müsste.
Stimmt das: Ihr seid gegen etwas
und sie für etwas?
Ich komme mir vor, als wären wir
Trychler als Egoisten unterwegs.
Siehst du das nicht so?
- Äh ...
Das ist ein happiger Angriff.
Den muss ich jetzt erst verdauen.
Ich hatte nicht den Eindruck,
ich sei für mich allein unterwegs.
Wir haben auch Tausende Menschen
nach Bern gebracht.
Die gehen nicht einfach auf die
Strasse, weil ihnen langweilig ist.
Sie haben auch eine Überzeugung.
Wie man weiss,
haben wir in der Familie Menschen,
die einen Impfschaden haben.
Wenn man dann aus Überzeugung
auf die Strasse geht,
um zu verhindern,
dass andere dasselbe erfahren,
ist das in meinen Augen legitim.
Das hat nichts mit Egoismus zu tun.
Da muss man schon eingreifen.
Gerade zeigte eine Studie, dass
weltweit mehr als 20 Mio. Menschen
dank der Impfung
nicht gestorben sind.
Das muss man klar sehen.
Das unterscheidet uns eben stark.
Du sagst,
20 Mio. Menschen wurden gerettet.
Das ist gut und recht.
Aber wir sollten im Jahr 2024
noch mal zusammensitzen und schauen,
wie viele an den Nebenwirkungen
der Impfung gestorben sind.
Das würde mich in zwei bis vier
Jahren wundernehmen.
Für mich ist das Thema
noch nicht fertig gegessen.
Hier am Tisch zeigt er sich,
der Clash zwischen Extrempositionen,
aber auch
zwischen Meinungen und Fakten.
Eine Herausforderung
für uns als Gesellschaft.
Konstruktive Lösungen
für die Zukunft -
finden wir die
überhaupt noch miteinander?
Du hast gesagt,
du würdest an die Menschen glauben,
weniger an Regierungen
oder den Staat.
Wie sieht das bei dir aus,
wenn man einen Neuanfang oder
Richtungswechsel machen möchte?
Da geht es mir ähnlich wie Jonas.
Ich glaube weniger an den Staat.
Ich gehe da
in eine ähnliche Richtung:
Dass man das Übel bei Gross-
konzernen, beim Geld, suchen muss.
Ich denke zwar positiv,
aber grundsätzlich ... äh ...
... sind wir
relativ negativ unterwegs.
Vor ein paar Jahren merkte man,
dass der Kipppunkt kommt.
Seither wird es nur schlimmer.
Das ist meine Überzeugung.
Und wir sind noch nicht am Schluss.
- Es wir nur schlimmer ...
Klar, könnte man jetzt
in einen Pessimismus verfallen.
Das verstehe ich auch bei Leuten,
die sich
mit der Klimakrise beschäftigen.
Sie sehen, dass nichts gemacht wird,
was dem gerecht werden könnte.
Wir leben
in einer um 1,2 °C erhitzten Welt -
das ist für viele Leute die Hölle,
jetzt gerade in Indien
mit den Hitzewellen usw.
Gleichzeitig
finde ich Pessimismus falsch.
Wenn wir alle finden, alles sei so
schlecht und es werde nicht besser,
können wir es direkt vergessen.
So möchte ich nicht denken.
Ich möchte glauben, dass wir
eine andere Welt schaffen können.
Klar, die Klimakrise
hat Schäden angerichtet,
Aber wir können noch viel retten.
Darum bin ich ziemlich optimistisch,
dass wir einen Wandel hinkriegen.
Viele Leute sind sensibilisiert,
mobilisiert und motiviert,
und ich glaube, dass wir
das gemeinsam schaffen können.
Vielen Dank. Ich hoffe es für uns alle. In welche Richtung auch immer.
Sodass der Neuanfang, den wir brauchen mit Blick auf die Ressourcen gelingen wird.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Jonas Kampus, Ella Frei und Roland Schätti.
Die Frage gebe ich weiter: Brauchen wir einen gesellschaftlichen Neuanfang?
Und wenn ja, wie schaffen wir den Neuanfang?
Oder, habt ihr schon einmal einen persönlichen Neuanfang erlebt? Welche Erfahrungen habt ihr dabei gemacht?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare!